-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show.
We're about to play a
mind-blowing game.
But, first, I'm going to need
someone to play against.
[ Laughter ]
Her new movie, "Amsterdam,"
is in theaters October 7th.
Please welcome the one-and-only
Margot Robbie!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Thanks, guys. Thank you.
I want you to know that
I am only doing this
because it's your birthday.
-I love you.
Thank you for doing this.
We're about to face off in a
game called "Blow Your Mind."
-♪ Blow ♪
♪ Blow your mind ♪
-Questlove -- Questlove,
do you want to explain
how the game works?
[ Hissing ]
-[ Echoing ] Yes, Jimmy.
In this game, I will read each
a mind-blowing fact.
And you must decide
if that fact is true or false.
If you choose wrong,
we will blow...your...mind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you will blasted in the face
from the tube in front of you.
Make the right choice, and your
opponent gets their mind blown.
-Okay.
-The first fact is for Margot.
True or false?
-There are more what?
-McDonald's.
-There are more McDonald's
in the U.S. than libraries.
-I would say that's true.
[ Music intensifies ]
-The answer may surprise you.
[ Buzzer ]
It's false.
-[ Laughs ]
What?!
-What just happened to me?
-Can we please see that --
No, silence, silence!
Can we see that in slow motion?
-Oh, my God.
This game is intense.
-Wait. Something
went over your head.
I don't know what it was.
I think it was feathers.
Alright.
-Jimmy.
-Yes?
-The next fact is for you.
True or false?
-How did she get
more McDonald's or libraries?
An ostrich's eye
is bigger than their brain?
-True or false, Jimmy?
-I understand,
but let me think for a second.
An ostrich's eye --
I don't even know how big an --
-True or false?
-I know, I know, I know
it's true or false.
-They're such big animals.
-Yes, but they have tiny heads.
-Birds often have small brains.
I don't know why I'm helping.
-I'm going to say false.
-The answer may surprise you.
-No, please.
[ Buzzer ]
-It's true, Jimmy.
Can we please see
that again in slow motion?
-What flew -- what flew on you?
-What in the hell was...
What was that? Was that lettuce?
-Do you have lettuce on you?
What -- How did --
It was lettuce?
-Your wig is doing
something special.
-You got feathers,
and I got raw lettuce.
-Is that what I got?
-Yeah, you did.
Margot...
-Okay.
-...you're up next.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
-True or false, Margot?
-Yes, Questlove?
-False.
-Margot, the answer
may surprise you.
-May, surprise you, yeah.
-Oh, dear God!
[ Ding ]
-Can we -- can we please see
that again in slow motion?
-What even came -- Just air.
-What came out?
-Oh, Ping-Pong balls?
Ping-Pong balls
just hit my face.
Who's loading up my cannon,
and who's loading up
Margot's cannon?
-I am.
-You can't shoot
Ping-Pong balls at me.
This is ridiculous. Alright.
-The next fact is for Jimmy.
-Yep.
-Jimmy.
-Yes.
-True or...Jimmy?
-Yes?
[ Laughter ]
-True or false?
True or false?
-I mean, if I'm in
the pineapple business,
I mean, I've got to
call Dole on this.
Pineapples take five years --
that seems...
-And they take no time
at all to eat.
-...impossible.
But there's a lot of layers
to a pineapple.
-True or false, Jimmy?
-Yeah, I know, I know, I know.
Yeah.
-That's hard.
-Pineapples take
five years to grow.
I'm going to say that is --
-I mean, you grow a baby
in nine months.
You can't, like...
-Five years to grow.
I'm gonna say that's --
that is false.
-Jimmy, the answer --
-The answer may surprise you.
-Yes, exactly.
[ Ding ]
-Pineapples take
two to three years to grow.
Let's see that again
in slow motion.
-Watch your --
Your cannon is going over
your -- One stuck on your nose.
Okay, good.
-What hit me?
[ Thunder crashes ]
-It's -- Uh-oh.
-Hey, that sound means it's time
for the final question.
And it comes with a twist.
If you answer incorrectly,
both of your minds
will be blown.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ooh!
Wait. Did he just say we're
both getting our minds --
-Yes, both.
-Gotcha.
-Margot,
this conundrum is for you.
-Look at my hair.
-Everything else
was true or false.
Why is --
What color is a mirror?
-What -- I feel like --
-Margot, what color is a mirror?
-Silver?
-What did you say?
Yeah.
-Maybe reflect...
-Well, guess what.
-The answer may surprise you.
-I bet it will. I bet it will.
-You are wrong.
[ Sad tuba plays ]
Let's see that in slow motion.
-What's the answer?
Margot Robbie, everybody!
-Thanks, guys.
-Margot Robbie, everybody!